Ці кадри облетіли увесь світ.
Українські військові несуть на руках поранену жительку Гостомеля під час евакуації мирного населення з Ірпеня.
На фото – Наталія Орлюк. Автівку її сім’ї російські військові обстріляли в Бучі.
Поранили ще й півторарічну донечку.
Я прокинулася від того, що чоловік розбудив і сказав: війна почалася.
І почалися вибухи, дуже сильні вибухи. Я відскочила з переляку і кажу: що робимо?
Чоловік каже: збирай дітей.
24-те лютого почалося для Наталіної сім’ї із сильних вибухів.
Кілька десятків російських гелікоптерів бомбили аеродром у Гостомелі.
Упродовж десяти днів вони всі разом ховалися у підвалі від постійних обстрілів.
Четверо дорослих і п’ятеро дітей - від півтора до одинадцяти років.
Ховалися. Тут лежанку таку зробили, бо спочатку ми на стільчиках сиділи, тут лавочку поставили.
А потім уже чоловік з кумом тут лежанку таку зробили. І це ми тут всі по черзі.
В основному діти, ми в основному сидячи.
4 березня ворожий снаряд залетів і до них.
Тоді вщент вигорів гараж, навіс та дві машини.
Ударна хвиля пошкодила будинок, а на кухні застряг один із осколків.
У сусідів - вигоріло пів хати. Тоді вирішили: пора виїжджати.
Ми написали на листках А4 "ДІТИ" великими і засунули їх у файли.
І потім скотчем ми обклеювали оце все машиною.
Їхали дев’ятеро в одній машині. Дорогою бачили зруйновані будинки та розстріляні, як решето, автівки.
Вони не знали, що ворог вже зайшов у Бучу.
А коли доїхали до залізничної дороги в місті - там їх зустріли російські солдати.
З дулом танк стояв, прямо на нас дивився.
Цей великий танк, отака велика буква V і двоє російських солдатів.
Показують жестом, щоб зупиняли машину.
Вони зістрибнули з танка, і чоловік вийшов, підняв руки, кричить: "У нас дети в машине".
Кума вийшла із сином і я з донькою вийшла показувати, що ми без зброї.
І він такий кричить: "Разворачивай, я тебе сказал!"
Та коли машина стала розвертатися, російські військові почали їх обстрілювати.
Я відчула гарячу кров, але коли донька заплакала - отоді мені вже було страшно,
бо  почала переживати, що їй залетіла куля в ногу.
І я почала на ній рвати штани.
Оце перша куля попала в машину, друга куля, це коли ми боком до них повернулися.
Це куля, яка прошила і, скоріше за все, влучила в ногу моєї дружини.
Дві кулі пройшло над машиною, одна, друга ззаду попала, і по колесах вони попали.
Жінка почала стікати кров’ю. Куля пройшла навиліт. А півторарічну Варвару поранило осколком.
У мене лилася кров. Я тоді не знала, що в мене пройшла куля наскрізь. Просто тут було отак кусок ноги, м'ясо.
Слава Богу, що не зачепили кістку. Я найбільше за дітей своїх переживала, тому що для мене діти - це все.
Ще одна куля ледь не зачепила 10-річного сина Наталі.
Я чув, як біля мого вуха куля пролетіла…
Вони доїхали до Лісової Бучі у пошуках допомоги. Місцеві дали джгут та привели лікарку, що рятувала поранених.
Я дуже відчувала біль. Я прямо кричала. Доньці зробили перев’язку.
Антибіотик тоді Ірина мені вколола і знеболювальне.
Оце мене тоді врятувало, бо я думала, що від болю можна вмерти точно.
Вирішили всі разом, що треба вибиратися з Бучі, тому що дуже небагато часу пройде,
і рашисти, ми так думали, почнуть ходити по квартирах, займуть всю Бучу.
Сюди швидше, під міст швидше.
Під мінометними обстрілами та ворожими літаками вони діставалися до мосту в Романівці.
Ти розумієш, що ти не можеш йти, ти поранений, ти в безвиході.
І чоловік мене взяв на плечі, переніс через міст, а вже біля моста мене забрали солдати наші українські.
У Києві в лікарні Наталі зробили операцію.
Там була відкрита рана і стояв дренаж. Сім’я вирішила їхати на захід країни. А далі - в Німеччину.
У Текленбурзі їх прийняла німецька сім’я.
У них двоє дітей, вони будинок знімали. І другий поверх вони віддали нам.
Вони плитку нам купили, електроплитку, щоб ми готували. Було ліжко, кімната була для Максима.
А Наталю завезли у госпіталь в Оснабрюці.
Мені сказали: терміново треба лягати, тому що можна втратити ногу.
І я півтора місяця пролежала в Оснабрюці в госпіталі.
Мені ставили оці їхні помпи, мене оперували, мабуть 5 чи 6 операцій було.
Оце воно виходить сюди залетіло. Теж знімали шкіру і пересадку шкіри робили. І отут вона вилетіла.
Це було як м'ясо, воно вивернуто було.
Хірурги зробили пересадку шкіри і маленькій Варварі.
Це нам вже зашили в німецькій клініці, бо в нашій тільки перев’язку робили.
Операції для сім’ї зробили безкоштовно – за рахунок німецького уряду.
А після реабілітації вони одразу повернулися додому.
Я хотіла додому в Україну. Я себе тут більше відчуваю вільною, відчуваю свою мову, мені краще тут.
У Німеччині мені було тяжко, я плакала, я всі новини дивилася.
І коли я побачила, що будинок вцілів, і потім я дізналася, що собака живий.
Я за нього переживала, тому що він наш член родини.
Джек чекав на своїх господарів удома.
Зараз Наталя потроху відходить від операцій. Нога все ще болить і спухає.
Трирічна Настя боїться виходити на вулицю. А півторарічна Варвара плаче, коли бачить чужих.
Та сім’я намагається забути пережите жахіття і радіти тому, що усі вижили.
Тепер у їхньому будинку – на одного жителя більше. Маленького котика назвали Джавелін.